Hello, The Internet I'm Gav.
Thank you for joining me
in this big empty void.
This video is sponsored by Google One.
Google One is a subscription from Google
that gives you more cloud storage to use
across Google Drive,
Google Photos, and Gmail.
So in order for Google One
to help us make this video,
I'm actually going to be
having someone else edit it.
And I'm going to upload all of the footage
from right here in the studio
using a little 5G bay station.
And that means while I'm
sweeping up at the end,
hopefully my editor is
already well on the way
to downloading the footage.
Here's a little bit of me
uploading yesterday's time lapses.
Behind me on the floor,
you may have noticed
that someone has come out
and set about a thousand mouse traps.
Unfortunately, that someone was me.
Took me about seven hours
yesterday. Had some close calls.
What I'm going to do is put
powder paint on each mouse trap,
trying very carefully not to set them off.
Different rows of colors,
so that when I set one off
we should get a glorious chain reaction
of mousetraps hurtling up into the air,
kicking paint all over the
place for a lovely slow-mo shot.
Unfortunately, due to the fact that
we don't really like to
waste stuff on this channel,
these mousetraps are old.
They were used in the trampoline video.
Because of that, they've
been sat in a bucket
for about three years.
Some of them seem to be one use.
Some sort of don't really function.
And some have rusted
beyond all recognition.
So I'm just very nervous, to be honest.
I'm just going to continue now,
finish setting them
up, and just get to it.
I cannot describe how
nerve-wracking this is.
I feel like the further
into this that I get,
the shakier and more mistakes I'm making.
I've only got what, like
12 more to place here
and I'm going to stop,
but it is nerve-wracking.
So as I mentioned in the intro,
some of them, the spring has snapped.
Some of them, the arm is bent.
Some of them, the wood
shattered on the first use.
One of them was burned. I'm
not sure how that happened.
Another trick I've learned is
to face away from the completed area,
because sometimes when you
are bending it back to set it,
it will just shoot out of
your hands, straight forwards.
It's not what you want.
I believe I have now set more
mousetraps than most humans.
Only those in pest control can
give me a run for my money,
I think.
I also might be up there in
most mousetraps purchased
with absolutely no intention
of trapping a mouse.
It's much harder than
doing it on the trampoline
because on the trampoline,
we didn't have to worry about proximity.
They didn't actually have to be touching
because we knew that the
bounce of the trampoline
would set them all off.
This one, they'll only get
set off if one lands on them.
So we're really just hoping for...
That is the eighth time
I've snapped my finger.
All right, let's do one
more, and then we're done.
Okay. That's all I'm doing.
Let's call it a thousand. It
probably isn't a thousand.
It might be way less than that.
I know I bought a thousand and
most of them have been used.
Let's call it 900.
Okay, before I put all the color on,
I'm just going to do a quick test
to see if it can indeed handle
a little splodge of color.
Okay. It seems as though we
can be quite violent with it.
I won't be, but that's good to know.
I am shaking like a leaf.
Interestingly, I didn't have
to buy anything for this video.
It was all stuff I already had left over
from various videos throughout the years.
So if it doesn't work,
we've only wasted money on
all the lights in the studio.
Now would be a very inconvenient
time for an earthquake.
But it is 2020.
Okay. The bag ripped,
almost dropped a full bag
on the side of the mouse traps there.
Also paying close attention
to my lab coat flaps.
Funnily enough, I spend most of my time
not wearing a lab coat,
so I do have to be aware.
Okay.
Now I'm going to attempt
here, on the smaller pieces,
just to push them up into position.
Number nine.
I haven't actually thought about
how I'm going to trigger them yet.
I think I'm just going to
chuck a couple of mouse traps
on the back rows and
hope that that's enough.
Feel like there'll be a lot of people
wanting just to skip to
the slow-mo on this one.
But for those of you stuck with me,
keeping me company on this
little journey, I appreciate you.
Oh, here we go.
Okay. This is it.
Yeah, I'm just going to
grab a handful of mousetraps
and chuck them on the back.
Okay.
Here we go.
Gonna run around there, hit the button.
Oh!
Yes!
Absolutely terrifying.
I hope I didn't run in
front of one of the cameras.
I don't know, I don't know
what I was doing there.
The aftermath.
Seems like most of them went off.
There's a little section here that didn't.
Most of them, I think,
did. I can't believe it.
I think I'm going to
struggle to do the outro
without a stupid grin
on my face after that.
I'm just so relieved it worked.
There was so much time and effort
riding on that going right.
Like if it partially went off,
or I had to sort of re,
oh, I can't even imagine.
I'm so, I'm so relieved.
Hopefully, you enjoyed that footage,
especially if you're able to watch it
on a 4K TV or something like that.
I'm very excited to get
it back to a bigger screen
and give it a look myself.
Big thanks to Google One
for sponsoring this video.
Every Google account comes with
15 gigabytes of free
storage, but sooner or later,
you will run out and
have to delete things.
So if you're sharing
files with family members,
the best option is just
to upgrade the storage.
Google One is a paid membership
rooted in cloud storage
with plans starting from
$1.99 for a hundred gigabytes
going all the way up to two
terabytes of online storage.
You can also use some Google
One features for free,
like the storage manager,
which helps you easily
find and delete large files
that's taking up your cloud storage space.
I love it not only because
I frequently have to upload
giant 4k raw Phantom files,
but also because it's so
well integrated with Gmail,
which I use for keeping
in touch with family
and friends and coworkers.
It's very seamless.
It's a service that I've
used for many years.
I rely on it, in fact, whenever
we're doing large projects.
There's often various versions
of videos to go up and review
and lots of Phantom footage to upload.
And the larger storage options
have really helped me out
and prevented me from having
to meet up with people
in real life, delivering hard drives.
So that's a plus for me.
If you think Google One
would be useful to you,
make sure you download the Google One app
or go to one.google.com to
explore the various features
and plans that you can get.
There's a link in the description below.
Thank you very much for sticking
with me through that video.
That was quite the process,
but hopefully you like the footage.
Make sure you subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video.
Time to get cleaning.
Oh dear.
Where do you, where do you even start
with something like this?
Oop.
Forgot about them.
I think less went off than I thought.
Big thanks to Google One
for sponsoring this video.